[Music]
yesterday as I've said several times
daredevil Felix Baumgartner jumped out
of a balloon at the outer edge of the
Earth's atmosphere he fell over 125,000
feet he broke the record for the world's
highest freefall almost 24 miles it was
incredible everyone's talking about it
the whole thing was sponsored by a red
bull well tonight we're gonna set
another record a daredevil is going to
attempt the world's shortest freefall
it's all brought to you by the good
people at slim jim behold ladies and
gentleman there he is
daredevil Alex Brenner suspended four
inches from the ground that's almost 102
millimeters holy that's incredibly short
yes of course his roommate and his dog
are in the crowd hoping for the best
here they are
[Music]
two-timing them I'm told alex is ready
to set a new free full record this is
exciting here we go 5 4 3 2 1
[Music]
[Applause]
had to put the dog to sleep ethically
the stress has taken its toll on yog
truly awe-inspiring airborne for six one
thousandth of a second let's see that in
slow motion Allen incredible there he
goes
let's see it of course from the helmet
camera this is going to be pretty
amazing I want to see that in whoa
that's incredible well our
congratulations to Alex congratulations
Alex a brittle bone disease